you know it's nice to win something like
the Nobel Prize but I feel a bit
uncomfortable and in some ways
hypocritical by about accepting it
because I've always believed that
accomplishments are objective but
accolades are subjective and the
accomplishments are things like you know
the idea for the thing that got me the
prize I got right after I quit from Bell
Labs and was walking my daughter around
in a stroller in the neighborhood and I
will you can always remember those
moments like they were just five minutes
ago I can remember that flash that I
wasn't even thinking about the problem
but it just pops into your head about
how you could combine elements of your
previous work to do something new and
then that idea laid fallow for 10 years
while it was in an industry and then
when when my friend and I were visiting
another lab we found about this photo
activated protein which was the missing
link and so that's another time that
again we'll always feel like it's just a
few minutes ago that you just remember
oh my god this is exactly what would
make that idea work and then a year
later when we actually saw that work in
the microscope when we turned on this
one light and these molecules popped on
all of a sudden it's like we got it it's
gonna work right those three events that
led to this prize you know those are the
things that you'll remember when you're
dying you won't remember exactly what
happened this week but you will remember
those those actual accomplishments and
when they happen